hi friends and welcome to the daily
Jenny from San Diego comic-con we are
here at the Hard Rock Hotel and just
behind me across the street in the
actual convention but let me tell you
all the action is really happening right
here at ETS comic-con suites all the
stars on the comic-con slate will be
stopping through here so needless to say
we are in for an exciting weekend ahead
and to give us a little preview of what
we can expect I got to bring in my girl
ash crossing at all you are so this is
the Super Bowl mix with the sugar a
concert look with my birthday well we I
know this is a lot of huge TV shows here
but also we don't talk about the movies
first and I know you have your finger on
the pulse girl what can we expect yes
here this year is definitely a bit of a
different comic-con there's only about 3
4 studios if you count Netflix so it's
kind of dismal compared to previous
years but if you are a superhero fan
this is a big one that's you
so obviously the Kingsmen was the big
highlight of the day we were a backstage
we got plenty of interviews come in that
way but Friday I'll be with the
guardians of the galaxy to cast but
Saturday is the big big movie day of the
weekend warder brothers at 11:30 a.m.
local time so that's Justice League
Aquaman ready player one Blade Runner
2049 and DC just added two new movies to
their slate so the speculation is that
they might announce officially Wonder
Woman - do you think patty Jenkins will
return as director absolutely I hope
he'll inflate it she has got my
prediction I love that and then later on
the day headlining the weekend at 5:30
p.m. Marvel has a 90-minute panel which
is very long and we'll have interviews
so we're likely going to be it's going
to be a big sore Black Panther push with
a little ant-man on the loss and
hopefully Captain Marvel because we just
got all our adventures a bidding war
stuff where we're running a focus on
those solo movies I know it's hard to
choose but what are you most excited
about
definitely the Marvel panel yeah and I'm
hoping Captain Marvel there you go
Captain Marvel Ashley thank you so much
I know you got some interviews to prep
for so we don't let you go fly out of
here Supergirl all right you guys for a
full Comic Con preview be sure to check
out behind the screens only on et's
YouTube channel the episode is up right
now ash killed it all right
but a huge film on the panel slate
today that just so happens to be
jam-packed with the biggest stars in
Hollywood is Kingsman the Golden Circle
the sequel to the surprised hit from
2014 stars Colin Firth again he was
seemingly not going to be in the
follow-up but we know he's back but
joining him are a couple of up and
comers by the name of Halle Berry and
Channing Tatum Kevin Frazier just caught
up with the cast about the new additions
to the Kingsmen family I'm drunk right
now
Todd that's what I want to know about
let's let's have a moment of truth
between the two of us was that really
bourbon did you really just bang down
all that bourbon I never drink in pill
[Applause]
never dare a girl like me to do anything
because I just you know make the
challenge how was it working with her oh
man like the first thing I think I said
it's just because I was nervous and
she's so beautiful but you know I'm just
like do you think you're the most used
name in rap songs he really did that
yeah that was my introduction to tanning
on this movie now one of the crazy
things about comic-con is we often get a
preview of the movies we will see or
hear about for another year
case in point valerian and the city of a
thousand planets the film stars Cara
Delevingne and Dane DeHaan has been
pounding pavement
since comic-con last year I got a chance
to talk to both of them and the three of
us could not help but gush about their
co-star Brianna here's a special look at
reread a bubble we meet bubble in a
cabaret club called glam club she right
away is an artist she's performing so
here's what we know about RiRi role as
the shape-shifting alien named bubble
she's only in one scene that took six
days to shoot and nine months of
special-effects working profession
taking August takes a shape
back-to-back-to-back-to-back you also
know she morphs into at least five
different looks
including a cabaret singer Cleopatra
Catwoman a sexy nurse and get this a
blog definitely a lot of changes a lot
of makeup changes and a lot of hair
changes the one that took the longest
was probably the Cleopatra look I'm sure
you do plan the movie set in the 28th
century was shot entirely on a
soundstage in the suburbs of Paris and
we're told even though Rihanna arrived
with her entourage she kicked them off
set when it was kind of get to work she
told they earned the respect of her
co-stars Cara Delevingne and Dane DeHaan
who plays the title role of valerian we
got to talk about Rihanna in this movie
Dane was it like for you to have a
front-row seat not just to RiRi but this
performance in particular when I would
tell people like what I was going
Peris to do they were really jealous and
their jaws were on the floor it's an
iconic said maybe Fisher incredible all
right that's it from day one of
comic-con be sure to hit subscribe to e
t--'s youtube channel so you don't miss
tomorrow's episode again we'll be right
here in this rocking sweet you guys and
of course stick with et online.com for
all the latest from comic-con i'll see
you guys tomorrow